something's coming
guys
aliens we've been calling them the
dominators that is not the name of a
species that comes in peace we must
exterminate your kind before the scourge
of your planet becomes disturbed of our
dumbest ships are coming your worldwide
Barry we can't do this along I don't
plan to
Oliver green arrow dig sport white
canary firestorm the Adam eight wait how
did you get the name heatwave
I burned my family alive I like to light
things on fire
what a colorful backstory well things
just got so much worse you really did it
this time Barry y'all call tech support
I had enough of this it's been an honor
know all of you to fight alongside me
now it's up to you to keep our home safe
have fun storming the castle
you go use Princess Bride against me
here we go
this came up ever
hey youtubers happy Thanksgiving so of
course they dropped like a whole bunch
of new crossover footage like right
after I do crossover video but we see
them go into the matrix all kinds of
dominators so let's break it down so
we'll talk about this and then like
tomorrow they'll release like a
10-minute version of the trailer so
it'll be crazy but this is your TV
Justice League here in the storyline
that they're doing like the way the
dominators explained the reason for
their invasion is actually straight out
of that comic book storyline so the
dominators learned that in the future
humans will be a big threat so they try
to pull a preemptive strike the cool
thing here is that Lyla and Argus have
known about this for a long time like I
posted that video with the viral trailer
in it I'll link it at the end of this
but they basically have footage from
back during like World War 2 era with
the Marine Corps fighting off dominators
and it looks like they're getting owned
like you see citizens steal here in his
full comic book costume nonetheless just
watching them go crazy on what looks
like this viral footages so we might
actually visit that moment on legends of
tomorrow like this black and white
moment is this same moment here on
legends of tomorrow they've gone back
into the past to see this this looks
like the heroes have been captured
because they're all wearing the same
jumpsuits just like they did in the
comics they kind of near it in the
trailer their ships landing all over the
earth so this is gonna be really
interesting to see how they try to
explain this after they solve this
problem I'm guessing it'll be a legends
of tomorrow type twist whereby they're
able to solve the problem of the
dominators by the fourth night but they
do it in a way that allows them to erase
all this craziness from the world's
memories because typically things like
this like especially in the comics if
you're not gonna carry it forward you
have to find a way to wipe everyone's
memories and the easiest way to do that
would be time travel there's so many big
blockbuster trailer lines in this like
they pulled a bunch of dialogue there's
just straight out of like some huge 200
million dollar movie you can't do this
alone I don't intend to
as they pan to this giant line up in the
warehouse here and if you look at these
boxes in the background - there's STAR
Labs equipment so whatever they're doing
here it requires hard core technology
Supergirl meeting the team learning
everybody's code names slightly longer
version of that funny heatwave moment
I burned my family alive and I like to
light things on fire this is actually
really cool
Oliver inside the Braille room they just
they call it the Braille room on the TV
show just because of the way the walls
look and it doesn't actually say
anything specifically they just made it
to look really really cool but remember
that during season two they lost the use
of Gideon or at least they didn't use
Gideon you know for whatever reason they
just didn't have access to it so they
might get that back because it looks
like Barry's learning about the future
just saying oh my god things have gotten
so much worse
Oliver at the mercy of the dominators
this might have something to do with the
arrow crossover there's been a lot of
theories about how they're gonna pull
off that alternate reality episode
whether or not it's a matrix situation
which it sounds like it is but then you
see a scene like this and it looks like
some weird portal of some sort so this
just like very arrow centric stuff
happening here the hundredth episode
there's gonna be so much stuff it's
totally so different from other arrow
episodes but it's gonna be a lot of fun
so Stephen Amell has said that they
tried to make it feel like a completely
different type of arrow episode like the
way it starts like the typical opening
they would do you know where he narrates
all that stuff is gonna be different so
that you understand that this is like an
alternate reality so it's gonna be a lot
of fun to see how that plays out all the
science nerds look like they play with
some dominators technology trying to
reverse engineer their weapons more of
the team reacting to Supergirl like she
just waved like she's having like the
most fun time ever and everybody else
just can barely believe it like oh my
god aliens that shoot fire out of their
eyes what the hell's going on big
team-up moment with the President of the
United States so it looks like it's
gonna be a joint military operation if
there are aliens all over the earth of
course you're gonna need the
government's help but the question is is
will they actually spin this into more
Justice League stuff in the future or
just a society or whatever they try to
call it it's just like way above and
beyond the team-ups that they've done
before so now we're getting to that Hall
of Justice
organized Justice League style team up
nice Princess Bride joke I'm sure
there's going to be a ton of those in
the episode so be sure to keep your eyes
peeled for movie references stuff that
goes like way above and beyond the comic
books most of it's going to be comic
book stuff but anytime
and now like citizen Steel's around they
always try to work in movie stuff like
this just a huge action montage of
scenes the dominators the actual
costumes are practical but there's a lot
of CG here too which actually looks
really good
Oliver boning the dominators with their
own weapons this character that Barry is
beating the crap out of here
doesn't look like livewire but it does
look like another villain or a
collaborator or a Dominator that just
made to look like a person I think it's
just another new comic-book character
but we'll find out once they list like
the IMDB characters usually IMDB is
unreliable until after the episode a
little bit of death stroke really like
the last 30 seconds of this trailer is
just like nothing you know very little
dialog just tens of millions of dollars
in hundreds and hundreds of man-hours
that it took them to make all crammed
into like this really small 30 seconds
in this really badass firestorm moment
here a lot of you are asking me about
this
like it looks like he's trying to
transform this entire ship he might just
be trying to make it go nuclear just
blow it up like imagine a version of
Superman's solar flare just unlocking a
really crazy new ability that he has not
done before and I think you can expect
the same thing from the other big
characters too like will price Lee Barry
do some stuff that we haven't seen him
do before usually that's what you save
for big episodes like this like they
have some insurmountable threat the
heroes have to evolve in order to defeat
them and the money shot so a lot of the
dominators storylines in the comics were
set in outer space or set in the future
like there was a storyline called earth
war there was a lot of Legion of
super-heroes stuff where the dominators
faced off against a lot of the United
planets of which earth was part so they
might work some Easter eggs for that
into this and like I said in previous
videos about the crossover a lot of the
story beats will be self-contained but
they will be carrying things forward so
like Legion of super-heroes is a really
big new thing that they haven't done yet
but we have Mon L on Supergirl he along
with Supergirl were big parts of the
Legion of super-heroes
so we might see them eventually pick up
and run with that on Supergirl
but I'm not really expecting them to do
a Legion of super-heroes TV show like a
spin-off TV show by itself I think it
more likely that they would do like a
Young Justice or a Teen Titan show or
even just Titans like another team-up
show but said in present day we've only
really seen the dominators in this
trailer footage so I think what they've
done from the comic book storyline is
that they've gotten rid of a lot of the
other races that were a part of that
because the dominators formed an
alliance with a bunch of other races
including the thanagarians the daksa
mites of which Mon L is apart and
obviously hawkman hawkgirl stuff gets
into thany guard stuff so I think just
in the name of simplicity just to keep
it from getting too insane this will
mostly just be the dominators attacking
earth by themselves so they have any
shout outs to the Green Lantern Corps
the Legion of super-heroes
or any other space-based races in the DC
Universe I'll be sure to add it to my
videos there'll be so many Easter eggs
it'll be fun to try and find them all
but my Supergirl video will post on
Monday flash on Tuesday arrow on
Wednesday legends on Thursday just like
you would expect be sure to subscribe to
get everything
so just a reminder that most of that
Supergirl episode will be like a
standalone story then like the last
little bit or like the last 10 minutes
or so will be crossover stuff that will
spill into like the full-blown
dominators storyline so everybody just
let me know like what your most hype
about for the big crossover
I really feel like just them even trying
it is such a huge deal that I'm so
excited just to see how it all works out
and it'll be interesting to see how they
try and top that next year like maybe
they'll do Warworld so be thinking about
other ideas for future crossovers Mongol
or just big villains they could face in
future years and I almost forgot is
Thanksgiving so giveaway time
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner mr. bacon
18 you win a $20 Amazon gift card be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details and I'll just go ahead
and start a new round again to just all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video you know the drill so announce the
winner the next time I post a DC video
where you guys wait for my next video
you can click here for my Marvel vs. DC
video learn why Kevin Feige is a huge DC
Comics fan you can click here for that
funny spider-man homecoming Tom Hall on
video thank you so much for watching
everybody high five I'll see you guys
tonight